okay das video durch das letzte mal
gezeigt habe hat über eine million
aufrufe bekomme
ich glaube die leute mögen es wenn luca
picasso ihnen beibringt wie man
kunstwerke erschafft deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht meine damen und herren ich
zeige euch heute mal wieder wie man
kunst kreiert eigentlich kann ich alles
außer kunst kreieren ihr vielleicht
wisst hatte ich vor einiger zeit eine
serie auf einem kanal in der ich mit
hilfe eines tablets und einem stift
youtuber in photoshop nachgestellt habe
die augen kann ich definitiv nicht so
lassen ich hab die beiden sachen hier
letztens beim ausmisten einer müllhalde
dahinten schlafen mal wieder gebunden
oder mir gedacht okay ich hab mir mal
ein paar bilder von youtube man raus und
zeichnet sich also herr ich würde sagen
gefangenen ersten youtube natürlich mich
vorbereitet und ihr seht schon die farbe
das für eine bestimmte farbe ich habe
jetzt mal ein bisschen nach unten
genommen die sache jetzt geradezu ein
bisschen rodel aus dem verband aus
farben mäßig also ich würde sagen wir
hier an wieder mit der sache die man
halt vor allem die wir hinter geht auch
der entdecker her
dann gehen wir hier raus und da habe ich
mir den vertrag aber freunde ihr wisst
ja das prinzip der serie ist wir dürfen
nicht das radiergummi benutzen nun hier
das ganze ein wenig ausfüllen und ihr
seht schon freunde wissen ein älteres
bild von mir ich hab einfach mal bei
google laser luca einige apropos laser
luca wenn ihr mir auch snapshot oder
instagram oder vielleicht sogar schon
auf antwort folgen sollte
mit dem mittlerweile wissen dass ich
sehr häufig mixtape hochladen auf
soundcloud deswegen ich will eigentlich
hier mit dem video weiter machen und ich
hab selber wenn youtuber irgendwie war
flammen nicht mit dem thema dem video zu
tun hat aber ich hab mir sehr viel mühe
gegeben im netz aufbauen cloud und
elektronische tanzmusik also hey linkes
in der beschreibung also check das gern
mal ausmalen hier eben noch den rest zu
ende führen das gedicht aus dann würde
ich sagen die hautfarbe haben wir
nächstes mal die haarfarbe ich glaube da
kann ich schon vom geltenden also hier
nehme mir die haare komplett
im gesicht ab und man hier wieder nach
oben bilden hier die haare wieder so ein
objekt auf jeden moment bin ich jetzt
mit den haaren welcher weiter geht's los
und machen damit das t shirt muss
eigentlich echt mal wirklich lernen
wieder wirklich mit diesem zeichen zb
funktioniert weil es gibt ja wirklich
leute und da bringt ja auch eigentlich
ein professionelles der irgendwie leute
die sich in beruf und ich mache damit so
eine scheiße hier vielleicht mache ich
gerade wirklich immer zurückgehen und
zwar hier die ganzen farben aus köln
hatten habe ich denn jetzt getan jetzt
kommen wir zum schwierigen teil und
verein seit den umrandungen und
andererseits auch dass wir jetzt
irgendwie wisst ihr was scheint auf den
stift gemacht dass mit der maus weiter
hier oben die haare rom hier wieder
runter und jetzt würde ich sagen
die grüne karte weil ich hab ja
also meine person schädlich hat grüne
augen nicht genau wie die grünen augen
von bis zu nehmen wir die wieder das
warten umranden hat ganz sonnen
beziehungen aber ein bisschen runter und
zwar nicht auf dem kriegspfad das ist
immer noch ein bisschen viel zu fett
die nase mit ihren auswahlen m den mund
nehmen natürlich in blatten brüllt dem
unteren bisschen zugekniffen also machen
wir den mund offen mit den zugriff
so sieht er nämlich aus hier in die
ohrmuschel damit in ruhe aus die haare
haben wir schon gemacht und ich würde
sagen meine damen und herren dafür war
es jetzt sogar ich gehe noch mal eben
mit einer etwas weicheren herzlich hier
unten lang und macht vermitteln dorthin
also wahrscheinlich werden jetzt leute
denken okay wenn er die sachen
auseinander zieht dann ist das übelste
kunstwerk ich würde allerdings mal sagen
freundlich stelle jetzt die decke auf
100 prozent der fall
der finale moment ist gekommen wie die
blue card wenn luca picasso ihn
gezeichnet
fakt ist dass ich gerade singe freunde
ich muss die unsere ebene noch mal eben
und herren also vielleicht das ganze
noch besser geworden
klickt man auf unterer ebene entfernen
ja es ist scheiße
youtube ist hier ein rausch der
einerseits wirklich bescheid über die
ohren sind andererseits allerdings auch
qualitativ hochwertigen red wieder
bekannte er
ich mache das ganz anders und zwar das
ganze mit den grün malen zumindest die
wirkkraft und nach ergeben bei den
details ganz einfach weil gerade bei 15
minuten drin und ich gerade mal erst
mich geschafft habe ich wollte heute
eigentlich lieben acht youtuber machen
die ich mir ausgesucht habe und
wahrscheinlich wäre ich auch ganz runter
müssen auf drei oder vier den dingen ist
einfach vielleicht hört ihr schon oder
seht ihr auch an ich bin angeschlagen
allerdings apple intern folgen laser
luca ich heiße sicher über laser lukas
auf youtube damals schon mitbekommen
dass ich ein bisschen krank erkältet bin
weil ich ja wirklich die letzte zeit hat
nur unterwegs war ich war in amerika ich
ja in die macht mit dem bart hier
nebenbei immer noch bachelorarbeit
schreiben deswegen kompletter so wenig
blog weil ich einmal selbst grant oder
uni zu tun haben also ja
aber ich würde sagen die beschäftigung
damit abgewendet doch gar nicht gehört
jetzt wirds schwierig räumt man nämlich
die haare gleich freudig oder zumindest
sind wenig greulich aber die sehen von
den verspiegelung hervor aus also ich
würd sagen ich mache erst mal hier kommt
so ein kleines ding hat mir echt gut
gelungen und jetzt mach ich das ganze
allerdings immer so dass man zumindest
die tasthaare sind bei mir sagen die
haare einfach nur komplett beschützen
auf meine haare sind doch so einfach
komplett bestritten auch keinen großen
unterschied aber ich meine abhol redmond
vorbild hinsichtlich rapmusik da muss
man wirklich sagen da kann man die haare
ich würde sagen die haare ich kann man
einigermaßen gut erkennen
die lippe wird so gemacht und hier
runter dann haben wir hier auch die
pläne die können nämlich in frankfurt
sitzen machen jetzt kommen wir zu den
details arbeiten meine lieben freunde
also hier einmal das auge umgeleitet und
hier auch beibehalten haben mit ihr die
wimpern hier die andere
ich weiß nicht welche augenfarbe er hat
ich würde mal sagen brauchen das findet
man in die braune kategorie packen ihn
hier braunen augen rein und ich würde
sagen ab packt die das spart man weiß in
den badezimmern ruhig weiter kleine
stocken drin und ist mein langes ding
aber ich habe einfach keinen bock hier
und das ist akkurat aber freunde ihr
kennt mich blue capital machte natürlich
nicht ende sondern ich schaue natürlich
noch ein t shirt an und wir müssen auch
noch weiße streifen hin und auch hier
wird natürlich die liebe zum detail groß
geschrieben wir sehen schon die streifen
werden hier perfekt ausgefüllt den link
sehen wir auch mal so fordert wir hier
hier und hier fordern ein streifen wegs
anfügen dann sehen wir hier oben auch
ausreicht und ich würde sagen meine
damen und herren damen haben wir
abgeschlossen
rettet wirklich mehr mühe gegeben als
bei mir und beginn deswegen will ich als
allererstes entfernen wir den
hintergrund thema eben
und jetzt will ich auch die obere ebene
packen ab über die kostenseite fertig
abgedreht sind nämlich so aus
wk
das ist unglaublich gut geworden also
ich meine warum wundert mich meine damen
und herren ich bin luca
runtergefallen deutlich wird sagen noch
davon etwa ebenen screenshot und
ausrüster damit ein hammer getweetet ihr
hatten abu raed bezeichnet also drehen
wir hier noch mal so schön wie ich ihn
mir dargestellt haben in photoshop wird
sagen wir schauen mal ein paar
kommentare an heilige scheiße bekommen
von ihren like auf jeden fall bereit zu
beginnen gesagt habe ich mir heute sehr
effektive youtube ort bereitet
allerdings nicht in der unterzahl gerade
bei 25 minuten kann hängt nicht umsetzen
weil fristen werde deswegen habe ich
mich dafür entschieden eine mitschülerin
einzunehmen die elektronik der bekannt
wurde ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass
van bos de angeli verlautet an adele
rankommt aber es gibt auf jeden fall
auch auf dem ganzen weg in die
geschichtsbücher einzugehen
[Musik]
auch weil biefang natürlich ganz
geschmeidig an mit der haut war ich
würde sagen da jetzt einfach mal mit
marc ellerich
ja da könnte ich komplett weiß nehmen
wie ist ja ein bisschen eine hellere
hauttypen überhaupt nicht negativ
gemeint ich glaube die meisten leute
wissen dass youtube mein gott wenn die
das ernste werde das ernste dinge falsch
hat mich ja selber sondern total
beschissen da gefällt also freunde in
letzter zeit kamen die natur in lucca
seeber gegen biel jetzt durch doch gar
nicht vielleicht noch ein bisschen ich
werde diesmal andere taktik an und zwar
werde ich einfach mal die komplett
hautfarben hier darstellen und dann
nachher einfach auf die hautfarbe die
ganzen sachen drauf rechnet vor habe ich
einfach mal ein bisschen platt fehler
von so jetzt kommen wir zu ihrer
wundervollen h brach die auf diesem bild
irgendwie blau ist ich weiß nicht warum
menschen schön da werden leute gefragt
sorgen männer mit mit braunen oder mit
blonder anstehen und kombi oder blau
menschen
das habe ich ja eigentlich sache ist
auch das wirklich denken von meinen zu
schauen und auch andere leute die dann
bekommen wir hier sehen wir zeiten
denken dann mühlen der macht ja nur spaß
hallo ich habe eine kunstgalerie aber
auch freunde nur eine kunstgalerie in
die gehört beispielsweise gebäude diese
gebäude dieses gebäude ohren dort
verkaufe ich meine kunstwerke
eigentlich ist meine kunst galerie das
hier
ich weiß nicht wie ich die dinge
darstellen der bikini aus 1000
verschiedenen farben besteht deswegen
mit einer grünen weil ich meinen grünen
passt zur blauen fahne war es unfassbar
traurig wie akkurat und ob ich mühe
gegeben habe und upgrades sogar bei der
community bei euch bei twitter relativ
gut angekommen ist und ich da einfach
ausgesetzt
ich hoffe dass ich bis jetzt
einigermaßen vernünftig darstellen kann
aber meine damen ich würde sagen sogar
auf kleinigkeiten natürlich acht gegeben
dass hier soll definitiv im herzen keine
kartoffel verdi wird auch wieder die
liebe zum detail groß geschrieben also
hier der schmuck wird noch schön
angebracht hier hat ein toller mann
wahrscheinlich gerade das armband 40
milliarden euro so wie ich die gerne wie
immer wieder von den fixen hätten wir
darunter auch vertreter hier kommen die
augenbrauen
wo sehen sie gar nicht mehr so ein
bisschen ausgehend von den fix und jetzt
immer noch weiterbilden nicht suchen
jetzt gebirgen umrandeten augen alter
dass sie gerade mega gut aus
lecker szene hier an gästen bis in das
hell pinke um damit die hilfe darstellen
jetzt haben wir hier ihr amt mit er wie
sich an den mund packt das half mir
natürlich die fringer und umranden bis
finden hier von hand wieder runter das
gesicht könnten wir auch mal ganz kurz
umranden ich merke schon wieder wie im
web baby wirklich mehr mühe gebe als ich
das bei mir folgen gemacht habe
die rechte an haben wir auch noch
angemalt dann geht jetzt mal ein
bisschen her im boden und nicht einfach
mal hier um ellbogen rom hier wieder
nach oben und bahn
wir haben baby einigermaßen fertig muss
wirklich sagen ich habe keinen effekt
ungefähr gespannt wie wir alle meine
damen und herren das video schon mal
gefallen hat weil die letzte person und
ich hab auch beckmann satellite da will
ich das normal machen soll und jetzt
meine damen und herren schreibt allemal
baby in die kommentare weil jetzt mit
das untere bild entfernen und das obere
bild wieder auf 100 prozent gemacht also
treue alle bienen kommentare scheine
gespann zeit und ich würde sagen 30 1
genauso beschissen ob sich das echte
fotos
[Musik]